tonight just hours ago prosecutors in
Chicago dropped all charges against
actor Jesse small at smollett you'll
remember was facing 16 felony counts for
faking an elaborate hate crime against
himself back in January
police say Smollett hired two Nigerian
bodybuilders to hang a noose around his
neck pour bleach on him and screamed
this is maggot country because that kind
of thing happens a lot in downtown
Chicago during the winter months
Smollett then told credulous reporters
he had been assaulted by two white
racist Trump supporters well as of
tonight police still believe that
Smollett was lying about all that so to
prosecutors they think he concocted the
hoax and they said so yet again today
and yet the state of Illinois is somehow
for some reason dumping the case anyway
in exchange for the hundred thousand
dollars he has already paid in bond
Smollett will walk free his record will
be expunged everything will return to
normal like it never happened so let
describe this decision as a victory
not just for him but for the broader
cause of civil rights
I've been truthful and consistent on
every single level since day one I would
not be my mother's son if I was capable
of one drop of what I've been accused of
this has been an incredibly difficult
time honestly one of the worst of my
entire life but I'm a man of faith and
I'm a man that has knowledge of my
history and I would not bring my family
our lives or the movement through a fire
like this
I just wouldn't now I'd like nothing
more than to just get back to work
and move on with my life but make no
mistakes I will always continue to fight
for the justice equality and betterment
of marginalized people everywhere uh-huh
okay a couple of pretty obvious
questions here what is this movement
some Alette refers to is he in contact
with other perpetrators of fake hate
crimes have they formed a union well
they hold a convention there enough of
them they could and how exactly is
similar to last we checked was an actor
on a TV show fought for the quote
justice equality and betterment of
marginalized people everywhere was
pouring bleach on himself part of that
fight how did the noose and the Nigerian
bodybuilders figure into small Nets
struggle for justice and equal
and by the way why aren't the rest of us
laughing at this it is just too absurd
CNN doesn't think it's funny they're
taking Jesse Smollett very seriously as
they always have
Jeff suckers tiny spokesman emerged this
afternoon to declare the whole thing an
unfathomable mystery of faith
like the Shroud of Turin we may never
know the narrative is once again changed
from victim you know to villain back to
victim it's been very confusing as as
Ryan was saying people don't know what
to believe and we may never really know
what happened on the street that night
in Chicago we may never really know so
it looks like we're just gonna have to
agree to disagree on this whole Jesse
small that thing but wait does anyone
know any news reporters they should have
some free time these days post Russia
hysteria maybe they could find out more
about this for example why isn't Jesse
Smollett concerned about the two white
racists he says attacked him shouldn't
he be leading the charge to lock these
villains up according to small that
they're still on the loose they're free
to assault other hapless biracial TV
actors we're just looking to get a
Subway sandwich at 2:00 a.m. in the
morning on the streets of Chicago and we
need to stop them before they do and
what about the Chicago Police Department
it's led by an african-american chief
but that doesn't mean it's not part of
the wider racist conspiracy it must be
Chicago cops just framed Jessie smollett
as a liar and destroyed his reputation
and yet for some reason somewhat doesn't
seem to care about that he says he just
wants to quote move on hmm that's odd
and what about the Nigerian brothers
last month both CNN and the Chicago
Tribune reported the men had told police
they've rehearsed the attack on Jesse
Smollett was that a lie well small etsu
them now for defamation other news
outlets reported that police discovered
rope bleach and masks in the brother's
apartment apparently smell its phone
records show he was talking to the
brothers immediately before and
immediately after the attack he alleged
what was that all about well we could go
on and on but why bother you know
exactly what's happening here
SWAT isn't getting off because he's
innocent he's not innocent
something better than innocent he's
famous the charges against him were
dropped because someone in power called
someone else in power and said let him
go none of this had anything to do with
justice is the opposite of justice even
and famously corrupt Chicago what was
happening was just too obvious the mayor
and the chief of police pretended to be
very shocked by it if you want to say
you're innocent of a situation then you
take your day in court
I would never if someone falsely accused
me I would never hide behind a broker
deal and secrecy period where is the
accountability in the system you cannot
have because of a person's position one
set of rules apply to them and another
set of rules apply to everybody else in
another way you're seeing this play out
in the universities where people pay
extra to get their kids a special
position in universities this is a
whitewash of justice a whitewash of
justice so how did the state's attorney
who dropped these charges answer that
well she issued a statement explaining
the charges against Jessie smell that
were dropped in part because of his
quote volunteer service in the community
okay what exactly was that service well
according to a news account tonight
Smollett spent a total of 18 hours over
two days at Jesse Jackson's lobbying
organization the Rainbow PUSH coalition
while he was there Smollett spent his
time and this is a direct quote stuffing
membership envelopes working in the
group's bookstore to sell merchandise
and critiquing it's Saturday broadcast
he also quote worked with the music
director on a plan to build the choir
apparently the community was greatly
enriched by all of this we should note
that Jesse Jackson who runs it is one of
the most politically powerful people in
the city of Chicago it helps to have
friends like that and if you don't
believe it just go ahead and try it
yourself go ahead and stage a fake hate
crime in which you slander an entire
group of people on the basis of their
skin color and political beliefs then
head over to Good Morning America and
conduct a tearful interview with the
sympathetic Robin Roberts describe
yourself as a victim of systemic racism
in this country
and then get caught doing it tell us how
you do then let us know when the
visiting hours are we'll come see you in
prison spots not going to prison he was
smarter than that he knew he would never
be punished
he knows Jesse Jackson he's friends with
Kamla Harrison Barack and Michelle Obama
Don Lamanna at CNN text Jesse all the
time on his cell phone and brags about
it
Jesse Smollett may claim to fight for
marginalized people but he is not one of
them in fact he occupies the highest
rank of privilege in our society he's
above the law increasing there seems to
be quite a few people like that in this
country you'll recognize him because
they're the ones always lecturing you
about how bigoted and unfair America is
what they don't understand is that they
are proving that point